y así aumento mis límites.
Cuando otras personas me ven poderoso
son ellos los que me conceden más poder.
Así que necesitamos herramientas para expandir nuestro alcance.
Y hoy les ofreceré un conjunto de herramientas para llegar a hacerlo.
Exponer el punto de vista es arriesgado,
pero estas herramientas reducen estos riesgos.
La primera herramienta se descubrió en las negociaciones
acerca de un hallazgo importante.
En promedio, las mujeres hacen ofertas menos ambiciosas
y obtienen peores resultados que los hombres durante negociaciones.
Pero Hannah Riley Bowles y Emily Amanatullah han descubierto
que hay una situación
donde las mujeres obtienen los mismos resultados que los hombres
y son igual de ambiciosos.
Eso es cuando abogan por los demás.
Cuando abogan por otros,
descubren sus propios límites y los expanden en su mente.
Se vuelven más decididas.
Esto a veces se llama "el efecto mamá oso".
Como una mamá oso que defiende a sus cachorros,
descubrimos nuestra propia voz cuando abogamos por otros.
Pero a veces, tenemos que abogar por nosotros mismos.
¿Cómo lo hacemos?
Una de las herramientas más importantes para abogar por nosotros mismos
es la perspectiva.
Y esto es algo muy simple:
hay que simplemente mirar el mundo a través de los ojos de otra persona.
Es una de las herramientas más importantes que tenemos para superar nuestros límites.
Cuando me pongo en su lugar
y pienso en lo que realmente quiere,
es muy probable que me lleve lo que realmente quiero.
Pero aquí está el problema:
es difícil ponerse en perspectiva.
Hagamos un pequeño experimento.
Quiero que todos sostengan la mano así:
con el dedo apuntando hacia arriba.
Y quiero que dibujen la letra mayúscula E en sus frentes
lo más rápido posible.
Bueno, resulta que podemos dibujarla de dos maneras,
y este experimento fue diseñado originalmente como un test de perspectiva.
Les mostraré dos imágenes
de alguien con una E en la frente,
a mi ex alumna, Erika Hall.
Y aquí pueden ver
que es una E correcta.
Dibujé esta E de manera que se vea cómo una E por otra persona.
Es una E empática
porque se lee cómo una E desde el punto de vista de otra persona.
Pero esta otra E es egocéntrica.
A menudo nos centramos en nosotros mismos
y en particular durante una crisis.
Y les quiero contar una crisis en particular.
Un hombre entra en un banco en Watsonville, California.
Pide USD 2000 o de lo contrario amenaza con volar el banco.
La gerente se niega.
Lo que hizo es dar un paso atrás y ponerse en su lugar
porque notó algo realmente importante.
El atracador pidió una cantidad específica de dinero.
Así que ella dijo:
"¿Por qué pediste USD 2000?"
Y él dijo: "Porque desalojarán a mi amigo
a menos que pague los USD 2000 de inmediato".
Y ella dijo: "Lo que quieres no es robar el banco
sino pedir un préstamo". (Risas)
"¿Por qué no vuelves a mi oficina para rellenar el papeleo?" (Risas)
Su perspectiva resolvió una situación volátil.
Si adoptamos el punto de vista del otro
nos podemos mostrar ambiciosos y decididos sin dejar de ser educados.
Aquí hay otra manera de ser asertivo pero aún así ser simpático,
y mostrar flexibilidad.
Imaginen que son vendedores a punto de vender un auto.
Es mucho más probable hacer la venta si dan dos opciones al cliente.
Digamos que la opción A es:
USD 24 000 para este auto y una garantía de cinco años.
O la opción B:
USD 23 000 y una garantía de tres años.
Mi investigación muestra que cuando el cliente puede optar entre dos ofertas
se vuelve más flexible
y es más probable que acepte su oferta.
Y esto no solo funciona con los vendedores;
funciona con los padres.
Cuando mi sobrina tenía cuatro años,
no quería vestirse y rechazaba todo.
Pero entonces mi cuñada tuvo una idea brillante.
¿Qué pasa si la dejo elegir?
¿Esta camisa o esa camisa? Bien, esa camisa.
¿Este pantalón o aquel? Bien, ese pantalón.
Y funcionó estupendamente:
se vistió rápidamente y sin comentarios.
Al preguntar a mucha gente
si se sentían cómodos
la respuesta número uno fue:
"Cuando tengo apoyo social a mi alrededor, cuando tengo aliados".
Así que queremos tener aliados de nuestro lado.
¿Cómo lo hacemos?
Bueno, una de las maneras es ser una mamá oso.
Cuando abogamos por otros,
superamos límites y ayudamos a otros a hacer lo mismo,
pero también ganamos aliados fuertes.
Otra forma de ganarlos, especialmente a los más influyentes,
es pidiendo consejo a otras personas.
Cuando pedimos consejo a otros, les caemos bien porque los halagamos
y se nos ve humildes.
Y esto realmente funciona para resolver otro doble vínculo.
Y ese es el doble vínculo de la autopromoción.
La autopromoción de doble vínculo
es que, cuando no hacemos públicos nuestros logros, nadie se da cuenta.
Y si lo hacemos, no caemos bien.
Pero si pedimos consejo sobre uno de nuestros logros,
parecemos tanto competentes como simpáticos.
Y el efecto es tan potente
que incluso funciona cuando se ve venir.
Me advirtieron varias veces en mi vida
que se le aconsejó a una persona con poco poder venir a pedirme consejo.
Quiero que noten tres cosas en este caso.
Primero, supe que iban a venir a pedirme consejo.
Segundo, realmente investigué las ventajas estratégicas
al pedir un consejo.
Y tres, ¡todavía funcionaba!
Me identifiqué con ellos,
me interesé por sus decisiones,
me comprometí más con ellos porque me pidieron consejo.
Otra situación que nos da confianza para expresarnos
es cuando tenemos experiencia.
La experiencia nos da credibilidad.
Cuando tenemos mucho poder, ya tenemos la credibilidad.
Solo necesitamos pruebas sólidas.
Cuando nos falta poder y no tenemos credibilidad,
necesitamos pruebas excelentes.
Y una manera de volverse experto
es apostar por nuestra pasión.
Quiero que en los próximos días
cada uno de Uds. se acerquen a un amigo y que simplemente le diga:
Quiero que me describas una de tus pasiones.
Pedí lo mismo a mucha gente y les pregunté:
"¿Qué notaste sobre la otra persona cuando describieron su pasión?"
Y las respuestas son siempre las mismas:
"Les brillaban los ojos.
Mostraban una amplia sonrisa.
Gesticulaban tanto que tuve que apartarme
y hablaban tan rápido que subían de tono".
(Risas)
"Se acercaban como si fueran a contarme un secreto".
Y entonces les dije:
"¿Qué sentiste al escuchar sus pasiones?"
Dijeron: "Me brillaban los ojos, sonreí y me acerqué a ellos".
Cuando seguimos nuestra pasión,
tenemos el autovalor de hablar
pero también tenemos el permiso de otros para hacerlo.
Seguir nuestra pasión funciona incluso cuando nos tachan de demasiado débiles.
Todos están estigmatizados en el trabajo si se atreven a llorar.
Pero Lizzie Wolf ha demostrado
que al presentar nuestras emociones fuertes como pasiones,
nos perdonan las lágrimas seamos hombres o mujeres.
Permítanme concluir recordando las palabras de mi difunto padre
en la boda de mi hermano gemelo.
Esta es una foto con nosotros.
Mi padre era psicólogo como yo,
pero su verdadero amor y pasión era el cine,
y la de mi hermano también.
Así que escribió un discurso para la boda de mi hermano
sobre el papel que desempeñamos en la comedia humana.
Y dijo: "Cuanto más vas poco a poco,
más puedes mejorar tu rendimiento.
Los que aceptan su rol y están trabajando para mejorar,
crecen, cambian y se desarrollan.
Interpreta bien tu papel y gozarás de tus días".
Lo que estaba diciendo mi padre
es que cada uno tiene una función y diferentes límites en este mundo.
Pero sus palabras también contenían la esencia de esta charla:
la función y el papel de cada uno cambia y evoluciona.
Por lo cual, cuando llega el momento
de ser un mamá oso feroz y un humilde buscador de consejos, hazlo;
Encuentra pruebas y aliados valiosos.
Sé un apasionado de la perspectiva.
Y si usas esas herramientas,
y todos y cada uno de Uds. puede usarlas,
ampliarán los límites del comportamiento aceptable,
y sus días serán especialmente alegres.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)